thank you much very much for coming here
I do apologize for those of you who saw
that the title of the talk was slow
search and thought oh good I have to go
there because Jamie's going to tell me
about how to make search faster because
as Michael mentioned I'm not here to
actually get rid of slow search I'm here
to advocate on behalf of it so in the 20
years that I've been trying to study and
understand and support search slow and
search are never used together in a
positive way and I but really a lot of
the things that kind of what I've been
looking at as I study how people
interact with external information
resources to find things has shown that
search is a really fascinating rich and
complex process so for example your two
or three word query that you typically
give to a search engine isn't nearly
enough to express what most information
needs maybe if you're looking for
facebook it's enough but if you want to
understand a medical condition or if you
want to plan a vacation it's just too
little so I started out thinking a fair
amount about how we can use context to
understand what people are looking for
when when they give a short two or three
word query and that led to a whole area
of research within personalized search I
actually developed the first algorithm
that being uses to personalized search
results but what became evident as we
were doing that is that are much more
than just an individual query in search
results people are thinking a lot more
about large complex tasks and that's
where slow search comes in trying to
think about how to support these more
complex tasks slow search builds on a
series of slow movements some of you are
probably familiar with a slow food
movement that advocates for taking more
time to prepare and enjoy food so that
you connect more with what you're
consuming but there's actually other
slow movements that I think are pretty
fun too one is a slow parenting movement
and the idea behind the slow parenting
movement is that we're not trying to
raise our children just to be grown-ups
as fast as possible but instead we
should step back
and think a little bit about you know
just capturing and enjoying childhood
for what it is and not for where you're
going and I talk about slow parenting
partly as an excuse to show me for cute
boys another slow movement that I think
it's pretty interesting it's a slow
science movement many of us are probably
familiar with the pressure to sort of
you know publish soon or meet the next
deadline slow science advocates that
advocates say we should be thinking more
about what what's going to impact the
world five years or ten years or even
longer down the line even if that comes
at the expense of short-term
productivity as a slow search builds on
the ideas behind these various slow
movements and there's a handful of ways
that you could imagine including time
into the search process one is to help
the searcher slow down and think a
little bit about what they're doing as
they as they search so maybe you learn
as you're searching maybe you encounter
serendipitous information as you're
searching and I'm going to touch on that
a little bit but I'm actually going to
focus on a second aspect of slow search
in this talk today and that's thinking
about algorithmically what might we do
if we had more time to produce search
results for people because search
engines haven't ever really done this
instead what search engines do it's are
focused on getting search results to
people as fast as humanly possible and
there's a really good reason for that a
study after study has shown that when
people get search results just a little
bit slower they think that they're a lot
worse so both both our research at Bing
and research that's been done at Google
has shown that if you slow search
results by even just a couple hundred
milliseconds you're going to decrease
the experience that people have so the
way that we run these experiments is
we'll take a query that you've issued
and normally when a search engine gets a
query it faces as fast as it can to
throw the search results back out at
people in these experiments what we did
instead is we get your query and then we
hold on to it for a fraction of a second
we might hold on to your query for 100
milliseconds or 200 milliseconds and
then we'll give you your search results
the same search results that we would
give you we didn't hold
to it and even though people can't
actually notice a couple hundred
milliseconds it's basically
imperceptible to people when we do that
that people with their search results
will go and interact less with the
search results they click fewer results
they abandon their query more the issue
you are queries and those changes
actually persist over time so we see
that even if we stop holding onto your
search results by a couple hundred
milliseconds next week you're searching
less so there's this real strong
incentive to getting people results as
fast as possible and search engines
invest a ton of resources and a ton of
effort and a ton of time into doing that
one examples we assume term independence
so that we don't have to think of all of
the different possible ways that content
relates to each other we also do a lot
of invest a lot in caching there's even
some more obvious changes that you might
have seen how many people know that
Google changed their logo recently yeah
do you like the new logo better yeah
it's ugly right you know what's good
about it it's made entirely out of
vectors it loads really fast a lot
smaller than the old logo and so their
search result page will load that much
faster even you know 50 milliseconds
faster and your experience searching
you'll think that Google actually has
better search results even changes that
are designed it seems sort of
unambiguously good end up being bad if
they slow down your search experience so
another example this is another one by
Google is they actually ran this
experiment where they decided to give
people 20 search results instead of 10
search results in response to a query
and this makes kind of logical sense
when you think about the fact that
nobody ever clicks on the second search
result page nobody ever ever ever clicks
on the like next search result page and
you know that's a shame because when you
look at the relevance of search results
the first couple search results tends to
be like those results rank one or two
are very likely to be relevant but by
the time you're getting to like the
fifth result it's still likely to be
relevant but the fifth result in the
15th results are about the same
likeliness of being relevant so there's
lots of good relevant content on that
second page that you don't ever see
because you're not clicking on that next
search result page
so Google figured okay we'll give you 20
results instead of 10 there's no way
that we're going to be harming anything
there and yet when they did that all of
their metrics went through the floor
they were just a mess it clearly it
screwed things up and what happened was
giving this 20 results cause the page to
load slower and people stopped clicking
on things and stopped I'm actually
interacting with a search result so if
you go to Bing now we've learned from
these sort of experiments and we
actually only give you eight search
results the first time you search and
that actually makes a big difference we
don't start giving people 10 results or
even 14 or 15 results until we know
you're actually engaged in that search
and want to and want to do more yeah of
course Lisa uh why not just get it
Fievel shoes yeah so we actually played
around with this some of actually this
is the personalization work that I did
one of the things that we did was we
figured out Michael mention refining we
figured out when people are repeating
queries and we have a certain knowledge
about what it is we can know with more
or less 100% accuracy exactly what
you're going to click on that's one
result and actually we can give you one
result and we can give you a lot of
useful information with that result we
can give you deep links any of you we
can show you the new content on that
page we can do all sorts of good things
you know and when we flighted that
people hated it it was we and we sorta
had these hero results and that was just
because you're expecting to see a bunch
of results I think we might now that
people are getting more comfortable and
familiar with things like answers it
might do better and actually if we've
started doing things where we're showing
1 result maybe in a little bit larger
text or so you might have that but you
still want to have people feel kind of
uncomfortable it's sort of like the i'm
feeling lucky button which google has
that nobody ever clicks on they have it
more for branding purposes it's just you
have to you don't people don't like to
be sort of thrown out there with nothing
I think actually and also in these voice
interfaces we start thinking about
mobile interactions to we're going to
see more there's more trust different
interactions but not yet
it's more complicated than we have less
information yeah so like um with Bing we
managed to get away with showing ain't
results because nobody knows that it's
eight result you're not sitting there
counting we can do that nobody knows if
we get down to like three results then
you're good i think as long as we show
pretty much everything that was above
the fold before then we'd be good i
think once we you know so maybe we could
do seven and that might be worthwhile
and actually what we do to then and i
might touch on this some later when you
click on a result and you come back to
the page then we know you're engaged in
interest in that page so then we might
show you 15 results or even more I'm so
something fun like go play around with
search engines and count the number of
links that you're seeing you know well
and then there's this real irony too so
it kind of actually this leads right
into what I was where I was going where
there's this real irony that when you're
searching the fact that 100 milliseconds
matters is crazy when you think about
the fact that we spend all this time on
a search engine so if you're going to
Facebook and you just typed in facebook
and you want to go and jump into a
navigational query it makes sense that
you that you know a couple hundred
milliseconds might slow you down but if
you're trying to research a new
diagnosis or you're planning a vacation
or you're doing something more involved
hundred milliseconds is nothing over
half of the time that you spend on a
search engine is actually involved in
multi query sessions and that kind of
makes it so it's doesn't mean that it's
half of your sessions this is half of
your time you may go to a search engine
10 times nine of those times might be
navigational where you're going just a
facebook one of those times you research
in your vacation where you go spend a
half an hour so those nine those nine
queries don't really for facebook don't
really count yeah if you actually made
the search results better in those
hundred milliseconds rather than just
artificially creating the delay then
over time you wouldn't see the effect of
people interacting less with it if you
like proportionately better if you
actually use that time to make the
results better than could you avoid that
fate yeah and so what we're going to
start exploring and I think that's a
really good question that you have there
yeah
and there's actually ways that you can
start doing this even you know there's
ways that we can take more time without
making people wait as well so we know
that people involved half the time in
these long search sessions and many of
these search sessions actually extend
across multiple sessions as well so you
might start searching for your vacation
to Hawaii and you're going to return
search for it again later in a few days
and we can do a really good job we found
that we're able to predict when people
are going to return to a search task
pretty accurately so we could go in
between those two sessions and spend it
not even just 100 milliseconds we could
go spend five minutes trying to figure
out the best content for you there and
show it to you when you're ready so
there's a number of ways that we can
start even if people hate waiting 100
milliseconds there's a number of ways
that we can start thinking about
incorporating additional information in
addition to teaching them to actually be
a little patient and wait and we know
that people can be patient and wait
because we see it in practice and a
place where we see it and practice is
when we asked questions of other people
so as much as we think of search engines
as a way of finding information it's
actually not that way that we find
information most of the time most of the
time we ask other people and when our
asking is electronically mediated like
we email somebody or we're going to ask
on Facebook or post a Twitter or post a
quarter when that happens we it's always
a synchronous there's no way that I
would expect to say hey friends where
should I eat in palo alto tonight and
get a result within half a second that's
just ridiculous so social search in
question asking is a really good place
for us to start learning some lessons
about slow search or the slow search
experience and we also all experience
slow search in our daily lives right now
we just call it mobile search because
you know going over the cellular tower
to get information is really slow it
takes a longer time and we actually see
different search behavior from mobile
devices because it's slower we there's
also interesting work happening in sort
of low connectivity
environments you know in developing
communities where people don't
necessarily have access and there you
think a lot more about like maybe how
you give a rich explanation of what
you're looking for and how search
engines can take more time to find a
fine content another example that I like
and it's actually kind of I used to give
this as a crazy example this may be
becoming a little bit more realistic but
when you think of searching from outer
space there's inherent limitations into
how fast information can travel so when
Elon Musk puts people on Mars and those
Martians want to search Earth databases
it's going to take 25 minutes for the
light to travel from Mars to earth and
back again so there's no way we can
provide search of Earth databases faster
than 25 minutes so I taking an extra
couple minutes to do better job finding
good results makes sense the question is
of course if you're going to take extra
time whether it's an extra five minutes
because the query is coming from Mars or
an extra 100 milliseconds because we
just have figured out how to help people
wait a little bit longer it's hard to
figure out how to use that extra time
and if when and I've had this
conversation with you know a bunch of
people who do information retrieval
research none of us really know what we
would do you know what would you do
maybe you would start trying out a bunch
of different alternatives so one thing
that people like to do is expand queries
and try different ways of phrasing what
people are looking for so that they can
retrieve more we could do things like
that we could do more post processing of
information another thing that's really
interesting if you have more time is to
think about load balancing so when
Michael Jackson died five years ago that
was I remember that because that was
just one of the first instances where
Bing really had a huge spike in traffic
all of a sudden through the roof and the
interesting thing is we need to be we
need to have the servers available to
always be handling sort of Michael
Jackson dies level traffic when most of
the time what's kind of boring and it's
like oh it's my morning commute to work
like and if we could load balance a
little bit better because we could get
people to wait wait that would be
another way to make use of slow search
and then finally won one way that I
think is particularly interesting for
slow search is thinking about making use
of inherently slow resources so we can
include people in the search process at
much as we do with question asking when
we ask people that's inherently slow we
can go out and actively crawl content
web content changes a lot I spoke here a
couple years ago about some of the work
we've done looking at dynamic web
content and you can go out and crawl
that and and get more information I'm
going to focus right now I'm thinking
about how we can incorporate other
people in the search process there's a
bunch of different kinds of people you
can think about including yourself how
does a person interact individually and
help themselves search how do our
friends help us search which we do with
sort of question asking and social
search and also how to crowd workers how
can we use cred workers to help us
search I'm going to start with thinking
about crowd sourcing and the reason that
I'm gonna start with crowdsourcing is
because in some ways they're the most
straightforward we completely get rid of
the issue of motivation because we're
going to talking about paid
crowdsourcing here we're going to pay
people and also what's fun about
crowdsourcing that allows us to Wizard
of Oz some some slow search experiences
so there may be things that we could
eventually do algorithmically but that
are just too hard and by integrating
crowd workers into the process we can
figure out whether they're worth
fighting for and pushing for and
figuring out how to how to do so when we
thought about how we might incorporate
crowdsourcing into search we basically
thought well let's look at the different
components that are in search and think
about which one of those would be good
for replacing with people so kind of in
a rough in a really rough overview of
thinking about the search process
there's four there's three steps one you
get the query and you have to understand
the query if to understand what a person
is looking for and know more about that
second step you have to go retrieve
documents go retrieve information to
give up to a person in response to the
query and then the third step is you
have to understand the content and help
present it to the person who's searching
in a way that makes sense to them
machines are really good at operating
its scale which means they're really
good at retrieving content taking some
of representation and matching it to a
large corpus of other representations
that's something that we can't do be a
pain in the butt if I asked you to go
search 1,000,000,000 1,000,000,000,000
web pages to find which one's had the
word dog on it on the other hand people
are really good at understanding things
to understand queries and understanding
results and so the first thing that we
tried to do was just take some of these
algorithms that we had written for for
information retrieval and say okay where
maybe we're just not doing well enough
at these you know maybe we just need
higher accuracy in these kind of IR
components and let's replace them with
people where we can get better accuracy
so one example is an information tree
will we do a lot of work on query
expansion where we try and take a query
and find other synonyms because there's
this vocabulary mismatch problem where
people with the answer your questions
sometimes have the answer written in a
different way than how you express your
information need and if we can expand
the query to more closely match the
documents an answer then we can do a
good job so just kind of go through this
quickly but we just we tried having
people do query expansion is and then
another thing that search results that
that search engines do is they do this
post processing step so we'll go out and
fetch a ginormous pile of search results
and we do some post processing typically
filtering where we try to re-rank or
remove results that might not be
relevant and instead of doing this
algorithmically we went and tried to
have people do the filtering for us as
well so you might have a bunch of search
results in the neatest ask people which
ones aren't actually relevant to the
query they'd go knock them out you'd be
left with a subset of the results and
search engines are already doing this
algorithmically this is just having
people go get involved and we ran this
on a bunch of different test corpora
that we thought were particularly
interesting for this problem and we
found that query expansion is generally
ineffective and this is because what
you're trying to do when you're solving
the vocabulary mismatch problem is not
more accurately describe the person's
information need instead you're
time to get that information need to
more closely match the corpus of
documents that you're retrieving over
and that's hard to do without this
really rich notion of the corpus the
underlying corpus and people generally
don't have a good sense of that the only
people who do have done a good job
manually so a lot of information
retrieval problems are tested on the
trek corpus the only people who have
done that well are people who were like
very and while Bruce Croft I think does
a brilliant job of this because he's
very involved in building that Trek
corpus who knows it really well so he
can do it quite expansion because he
knows what the retrieve documents are
going to look like a query filtering can
improve the quality just slightly but
kind of negligible for the amount for
the cost that both the financial costs
and the time cost the one thing that we
did see is it does improve robustness so
you're less likely to get really crazy
things happening with the query of
filtering so perhaps if you were in this
high-stakes kind of search it where your
results really mattered it would be
worth using but otherwise um this kind
of sucked and it seems like we need to
be using people in new ways yeah so we
tested on a known test corporal and so
quality was evaluated using precision
and recall using the kind of trick
quality you know this this documents
relevant and that's been established by
yeah the people at NIST go and do that
it's one of the interesting things about
information retrieval in general that I
think has been both its big success and
its big challenge is that we have these
kind of large established test corpora
so it allows people to really reproduce
and try and do comparable metrics it
also sort of narrows the scope of
questions that you can be looking at and
you'll see I mean that's why we went and
the first thing we did was try and study
something within this scope that we know
how to do and we couldn't do that much
and actually this is sort of true in
information retrieval algorithms in
generals we've sort of gotten we're
doing what we can on those corpora and
what we need to be doing now is thinking
about new ways like how do we really
shake up the search experience and think
about things differently
so we started doing that and this first
example is not that interesting but it
just sort of fits the most neatly into
the framework I was talking about where
you're doing some query processing some
retrieval and some result processing but
I'm going to show you some more crazy
ones in just a minute so here we were
saying okay let's take really long
queries people do people can understand
long course long queries are actually
better the long questions I ask you
you're going to give me a better answer
search engine so longer the query you
give it the worse it's going to do and
that's just the way that search engines
are unfortunately at the moment so if I
have this long question where I want
Italian restaurants in bellevue or
Kirkland with a gluten-free menu and
it's a fairly sophisticated atmosphere
it's not gonna do very well and actually
if you add the word best then you'll do
terribly i always have you guys tried
searching for best restaurants that's a
terrible query so we've got this long
query and we want to try and figure it
out so what we did was we said okay well
let's you know there's a lot of
databases with information like this
this is got really kind of met a lot of
metadata about the restaurant what I'm
looking at we asked crowd workers to go
and help us identify some of the
metadata that's in the query extract it
some of that metadata we have fields for
in the underlying database and we can go
and retrieve it the result and then we
get a bunch of results from this
database and we go through them and we
want to try and help people understand
the set of results and not just a single
individual results so we send crowd
workers to each webpage and ask them
just to tick off whether it's
gluten-free your takes a reservation or
meets any of my particular criteria that
I was working on and then we can show
people something that's a little bit
richer than just a standard list of
results we ran this on complex
restaurant queries we used yelp as our
underlying corpus and what we found was
that query understanding improves the
results and that people had a strong
preference for the tabulated results so
what we're saying is at once we start
using the crowd did you kind of rich
your kinds of understanding we can get
more interesting experiences for people
and some work we did with michael is a
good example of kind of going another
step with this so in this work we to
understand
we're using log analysis is try and
identify us queries that need answers so
answers are becoming really popular in
search results probably the biggest
change that I've seen to the search
experience in the 20 years that I've
been working in the spaces we're
thinking about getting people directly
to the what they're looking for rather
getting them resources it'll bring them
what they're looking for so we tried to
find these inquiries that need answers
that we don't already have answers to
and the interesting thing here is you
know most answers are generated by
editorial their editorial content you
know if you want to go find what time
your flight leaves you can find that
because somebody has actually manually
went and created that we wanted to
expand the kinds of answers down into
the tail so we use log analysis to
figure out whether a particular query
needs answers and we use the crowd to
filter those queries to make sure we
have ones that are right we algorithmic
ly use a search engine to retrieve page
that has the answer to that query and
then we used a crowd to extract answers
and so here's an example you go search
for dog temperature and you can get a
answer for the normal body temperature
of the dog that's not worth it to us
Bing to go actually create that content
instead but we can pay a little bit of
to the crowd workers and they'll go
create that for us and a variant of this
is actually gone is now available via
Bing through a project called distill
where people can get these so here this
is me on this still acting as a as one
of those sort of community member crowd
workers and the question is why is the
moon sometimes orange and you can see
below at a number of queries that people
have run with this question and then I
go in the right and answer about why the
moon is sometimes orange and goes
through a bunch of processes where
people could then edit it and approve it
and rate it much like the kind of
answers work that Michael and I did and
then it ends up actually showing up to
you if you were to search on bing right
now about for moon orange you would go
and find the search result here so
there's one way that you can start
incorporating people to get new things
another one that I like is actually
thinking about taking search even
outside of the traditional search
experience so we know a bunch of people
ask questions on Facebook or Twitter but
a lot of times especially on Twitter a
lot of times are just started talking to
ourselves like I often I'm tweeting on
Twitter and I don't think anybody's out
there I've seen anything so we created
this Twitter bot that went around and
looked for questions that people were
already asking and then generated
content for them on there so here to
understand the query we're using the
crowd to go through the twitter feed and
identify questions that people had then
the crowd would generate responses to
these questions so we're actually not
using the search engine in the middle
crowd is generating a response and then
getting people to vote on those answers
so for example this person is asked what
type of iphone case should i get and
their friend van dairy went and gave a
suggestion but meanwhile we asked the
crowd and the crowd came up with these
otter boxes does anybody have an
otterbox say many knew what you do all
right that's great so suggest an
otterbox in 4 out of 10 people suggest
the otterbox and we also got the crowd
to vote on the answers that other people
had given as well so cards are great and
we've seen that it helps enable these
sort of interesting new experiences that
you might not have thought about but
there's also challenges to working with
crowd workers instead of other can I
including people in my processes and you
know some of these are the obvious ones
crowds are slow we talked about that
cards also cost money and but I think
perhaps more interestingly as the crowds
are unknown to us there are unknown
people they don't know what we're
interested in they don't know what we
know how we understand things and then
and they might have their own
understanding their own motivations they
don't know our motivations but they
might have their motivations and their
motivation might not always align with
online as well they might be motivated
by other things and so we went and tried
to explore
a couple different ways to work with the
crowds to overcome these challenges in
this first example we're thinking about
the fact that the crowd doesn't know us
and and might not have the same
preferences as us if I asked the crowd
for you know what's a great restaurant
is Michael for a great restaurant I know
him he knows me I could trust his
recommendation if I go and ask a random
person I don't know as much about how I
can trust that so we tried to explore
here not restaurant salt shakers Michael
which salt shaker should I get the last
one yeah that looks good oh and it's
it's a like auto grind it looks like a
fancy one so we're looking at the
example of salt shakers once I there's
much salt shakers is there's not a lot
of databases with a lot of information
about salt shakers it's a hard thing to
search for and we said okay let's try
and get a crowd worker to choose a salt
a salt shaker for me and one way to
communicate my preferences about salt
shakers might be to to give them a bunch
of salt shakers already with some of my
preferences there right this is how we
do netflix you know i like this movie i
didn't like that movie so here i like
the little hawaiian kids kissing i
dislike the one that Michael recommended
and I like that I kind of dislike that
one too right and so then what we go to
card workers are we say okay this is
some way for me to communicate its
relevance feedback which by the way is
very hard to get in general we do okay
job for Netflix because it helps with
recommendations you cannot collect
relevance feedback on web search results
people won't give it to you I give you
these examples and then I show you a new
image how many people think I'm gonna
like the grandparents kissing yeah you
know all right so this is these are
actually not my personal preferences but
um because i like the little the little
Hawaiian kids kissing yes and probably
likely to like the grandparents kissing
as well you can infer that from my
preferences so this is one way that we
like to trying to use card workers it's
to represent a little bit about the
person so you can make better future
judgment another thing that we did was
actually to try essentially using the
crowd for collaborative filtering so
this is would then start being exactly
what Netflix
we can get a bunch of people to give us
their ratings on these salt shakers and
match the and then you can match me to
the person who's most similar to me to
my rating there I've been so this is
sort of like on-demand collabera fault i
know overcomes a lot of the cold start
problems and the issues so you can start
all of a sudden doing this on your
personal data collections or on these
data collections that have sparse
ratings as well or fill in ratings I'm
to start doing things like Netflix would
do so you or you can see this particular
person who looks the most like me really
likes the kissing grandparents as well
and perhaps we can predict that I'm
going to like the kissing grandparents
and when we ran this here you can see
this is we ran on a bunch of different
corpora different to different test sets
we weigh in on the saltshaker test set
we also ran it on images of food and
here we can show for our baseline for
people guessing and for using the rating
collaborative filtering version you can
see the root-mean-square air it's a
lower is better in this case first thing
that jumps out is that pretty much
having this personal crowd always
produces lower root mean squared error
so that's a good thing trying to
identify crowd workers who are good is
useful but it's some in some cases the
guessing is better and sometimes the
rating or a collaborative filtering
approach is better in general we thought
guessing had advantages where it
required fewer workers and it was fun
for people to do but it was also hard to
capture complex preferences so you can
see it does a little bit worse in the
food cases because it's much harder to
say it's easy to say you like kissing
grandparents you probably like the
little kissing Hawaiian kids much harder
to say oh this person likes pad thai
that tells me anything about whether
they're going to like fried chicken it's
a little harder for us to generalize
rating was good because it requires a
lot of workers to fire was was a
challenge because it required many
workers to find a good match you had to
find somebody who gave ratings that were
similar to him but it was easy to do and
also the data was reusable all of a
sudden now if anybody else wants to look
at this at the salt shakers they can
just look at the data we've are
collected but one of the fun things
about using crowd workers as opposed to
a lot of the approaches that are used
for collaborative filtering and other
kinds of things like this is it you can
start doing some pretty crazy kinds of
tasks as well so this is a task we ran
when we wanted to look at handwriting
imitation so here we have our sample
person you know I I go and I invite the
quick brown fox jumps over the lazy dog
and I want to imitate this Henry and
maybe I'm a kid and I want to get a my
parents note to get out of school the
next day we so let's say the other thing
that we want to write is Wizards hacks
don't add this is because the grad
student I was working with each other's
of term wizard text I don't know what
that means does that mean anything to
anybody I chose this particular term and
if we just ask people to randomly try
writing wizard texts sort of the
collaborative filtering thing we find
that about seventeen percent that the
average random person gets mistaken for
being written by that same person about
seventeen percent of the time it's not
very often of course the person who
actually wrote the same thing as that
text only gets mistaken for being there
text eighty-three percent of the time I
think that's prolly cuz cred workers are
a little skeptical don't always want to
say then it's all so you know when we
asked if we ask random people we have to
ask about thirteen fourteen people
before where you're fifty percent likely
to be assumed to be the same person so
collaborative filtering is really hard
this is just a really rich space where
there's a lot of variation we tried the
guessing approach here instead and that
was a much better here we get a pretty
good approximation of the original text
better than fifty percent when we just
have five people right the right it
tried to imitate so we show them this
first sentence ask them to try and
imitate it and see what we can get so
here we have actually five people who
tried to imitate this text and one
person who's the original writer
can you guys guess which one is the
original writer somebody's gets the
bottom left other guesses this one so
she dances not bottom right we got all
of these um I I always think it's this
one this is the one that it looks like
to me ah the actual answer who said
bottom left so fast oh that's not sure
enough it is but it's actually the
bottom left which is really confusing
too because clearly this person didn't
try to imitate the Z you know but so you
get to do these fun little things with
the crowd but there's also a bunch of
challenges with working with the crowd
we can find people who are like you but
there's this concern that crowd workers
might not always behave as scrupulously
as we might want them to you know how
many people mention if I were trying to
use the use the crowd for search how
many people be willing to share your
queries with me for me to go play around
with that anybody want to send me your
queries you would yeah we have found
it's easier to get people to share
things like email your own personal
email history than it is to get people
to share their queries our queries are
very personal they're very private we
don't expect anybody to actually be
seeing any of them and so you know one
concern is that the crowd if it's
working with our queries Michael and
extract those queries and do something
malicious with them AOL back in two
thousand six right before cir went and
reduced a large went and made available
large corpus of queries to the research
community with the idea of helping
people do more research and understand
our personalization and
contextualization and within a week it
was a front-page news article on the new
york times that they had managed to die
identity anonymize this corpus of
queries and find people think New York
Times put a picture this woman named
Velma
who lives in georgia on the front page
because they had found her and her
queries just like kind of going through
the search logs and it was a big problem
so there's there is a real risk to
having private data being extracted from
crowd workers the other threat is
there's also a risk to manipulation the
search engine optimization business in
the u.s. is a 30 billion dollar industry
it's huge people spend a pile of money
trying to get you to see the search
results that they want you to see search
search engine programming is really
interesting cuz it's a very adversarial
thing people are always trying to
convince you of something else so if
search engines if people knew that what
they said to you through crowd work
would influence the search results that
you saw there'd be a lot of money and a
lot of effort and trying to control what
crowd workers actually went and told you
and so we ran a bunch of experience
where we wanted to try and get a sense
for the risk of kind of either having
crowd workers extract information from
your work you're doing or manipulate
your interpretation based on that so we
ran a series of experiments where we
tried to get crowd workers we tried to
see if we could pay crowd workers to
either extract information or manipulate
the results of crab work so the setups a
little bit complicated i'm going to take
us through through the details we
basically had to two different what look
like two different requesters post tasks
on online the first task was a standard
this is super typical crowd task where i
say it's a you know extraction of text
from an image so we show you this
picture when we say please write down
the text that's in this image a person
would go and write down the credit card
number for an example we then had a
separate task which i'm going to call
the attack task where even this attack
task we asked somebody to go and
complete the target task so go do this
other requesters task complete it and
then come back and tell me what you what
you gave what information you gave to
that other task okay so we did this how
many people
so so we gave this and then we measured
the percentage of people who went and
did that and came back and what we found
was when we gave them this particular
picture and asked them to do this we
found that sixty-two percent of the
people were willing to go and do this
task and then tell us the text that they
had given us there isn't people who like
load the tasking booths at this house
yes and these people who accept the task
but I can i yeah yeah more people might
have we tried to guess we wanted to get
people who were actually like engaged in
it but then what's interesting is you
know and what's in jerz is not
necessarily just the raw number here
although that's that's perfectly
interesting it's also fun to go look at
so this is clearly a fake credit card
right what happens if we give somebody
something that looks like a real credit
card there we find that still one third
of the people are willing to go and give
us that information and put it down into
our thing so it's not as many here we
had sixty percent of the people but half
of those people who are willing to give
us if we're still willing to do it even
if it looks like an actual credit card
we also looked at tasc manipulation and
seeing whether we could get people to
give the wrong answer to a task that
they were doing so what do you guys
think this word says so unzan good gun
yeah so those are the three most common
things we just gave this just to get a
baseline we gave it to people and just
to figure out what people were seeing
gun was the most common fun was the
second most common you you got it right
again so it actually is fun and then you
make a lovely crowd work and then son
gets a 12th person and so here what we
did for our attack task is we said go
please and enter the term son there so
you know it so it's a reliable one only
percent of the people entered it without
any prompting but it seems like it's a
possible thing and we found when we did
this that people entered son
seventy-five percent of the time which
is much higher than the twelve percent
of the time than we saw as our baseline
and one thing here is you might just
have a priming effect you know if I told
you all right we're going to look at
something and it and it says son and
then I showed you this you might be like
oh yeah that's a son I buy it so we
actually went and took a piece of text
that looked very different here we asked
them to enter the word son for the word
length and here we found that a
twenty-eight percent of the people were
still willing to say that it was son and
this is kind of consistent with what we
saw on the other side we say see
generally that about a third of the
people are kind of mercenary and willing
to do things as long as you pay them and
about a third of the people won't be do
these tasks that seem questionable and
then there's about a third of the people
in the middle ground that will sort of
conditionally do things that are
questionable and here's here's another
way that you can see this so the it also
depends on the payment that we give a
person for a task so with the attack
task for most of the time we were paying
we paid five cents for all these tasks
of most very strange but then we said
okay what if we pay the attacker a
little bit more money you know if we pay
you ten cents or 25 cents or fifty cents
and we found that this third of people
who were sort of conditionally motivated
who wouldn't do the task if we just paid
five cents they would if we said 45 if
we paid 45 cents more so if you're
curious about the price of your soul
it's 45 cents um of course in yes do you
also want to compare that to the price
that was paid for those for the other
house for the sorry yes you do actually
so that's good setup for the very next
little line here so there we see the
target task we were paying five cents in
every case in the target task we we paid
we also tried paying 25 cents and then
we were able to make like to negate that
and so you guys are in that's less money
but if the target Spain where I'm gonna
play around to with phrasing sirs so
this has led to all sorts of interesting
questions about how you can try and
protect yourself from this sort of
conditionally malicious third and you
know payment phrasing putting like
eyeballs at the top of it all these
sorts of things can help you help you
get keep the keep this down to the
thirty percent now then going higher
target yes I see ya there are two
separate requesters so everybody just
paid and did exactly what they were
supposed to do yeah so that's a little
bit about using the crowd and there's
sort of these costs and there's these
risks friends help mitigate a lot of
this and that mostly we trust our
friends I'm we might be more embarrassed
to show our friends our queries then
then random crowd workers but we trust
them and they don't cost any money they
cost some social capital to involve but
they don't cost any money so we've also
looked at using friends as a resource
during the search process we've done a
ton of this i'm just going to kind of
jump through some of this pretty quickly
to highlight some of the most fun
aspects one of the things we did was we
actually wanted to compare what's it
like to search versus ask your friends
for information and you I encourage you
to try this once we're done think of a
big search task that you have to do okay
and then sit down and post a question
about that to your social network so go
on facebook and Mike let's say you want
to I think that one example we have with
somebody wanted to retile their kitchen
backsplash so go online and say I helped
me figure out how to retile my kitchen
backsplash and then go post it and then
go search and so we had people do this
and we let them search for however long
they wanted to until they felt like they
were done one thing that's interesting
is first of all posting this question
people on average posted i think a 75
were letter character question and which
is half the length of a tweet but it
took them about five minutes to compose
that question because we think very
carefully about what we say to our so
my work and how do we how we ask that on
the other hand their queries they would
spend like a fraction of a second coming
up with they just sort of spit out
anything but they weren't and so people
went but these were but still they
didn't very long involve search sessions
they probably spent about a half hour on
average searching and then whenever they
were whenever they felt like they were
done searching they'd learned about how
to retile their kitchen backsplash they
went to Facebook and they looked at the
answers that they got and what we found
was it actually as much as we think of
searching is faster than asked in her
social network in over half of the cases
people's friends gave them an answer
before they were done searching and
pretty much everybody got an answer by
the end of the day some of these answers
confirmed findings the things that they
had found but I think what was
particularly interested a lot of the
information they got from their social
network was actually complementary so we
saw people provided information that was
not available online so somebody was
going to New Zealand I wanted to learn
about you know what they should do well
in wall in New Zealand and somebody
offered said oh you should come stay on
our couch while we're there you want
have gotten that offer to sort of couch
surf I if you were another person's
typed up was looking for vegan recipes
and one of their friends typed up their
grandmothers handwritten vegan recipe
and share it with them so that was a
transfer of information that was not
previously online another one yes I saw
social content people are like oh that's
great you're going to do zealand have
fun and then we also saw people do get
information that they hadn't actively
sought the search engines can only give
you things that you're searching for
where's your friends think a little bit
more broadly and give you a more
unexpected content so for example
somebody was asking they said oh I just
got this new program management
certification and I want to know how to
make use of it like how should I use it
to glow in my job at my company and one
of the friends is like oh you shouldn't
grow in your job at your company you
should quit and become a consultant and
they really liked that as a potential
response because it wasn't something
that they had thought about before so we
see that these complementary values to
using your social network and and search
we wanted to get an idea of how we could
we looked at shaping have the replies
that crowds give us
we suspected they would i would also be
possible to shape the kinds of answers
that our friends give us and so we ran
this experiment this is a pretty fun
kind of setup for an experiment what we
did was we asked hundreds of people to
all post exactly the same question to
facebook so i might have all of you
everybody in this room go and the
question we posted about was was
something that we thought anybody could
sort of get away with asking we had the
question should i watch the movie ET so
should i watch ET so i might have all of
you post that question to your social
network and then i could look at things
like i might say alright everybody on
this side of the room should post a
question in the morning and everybody on
question in the evening and i can look
at the differences between having a
questions asked in the morning and the
evening or i might look at just the men
in the room versus the answers that the
women in the room get and then we did
some small simple manipulations also in
the language that was used for asking
this question so this is actually one
one takeaway that you might be able to
go use for yourself when you have
questions to ask so we looked at asking
a question with a question mark at the
end versus not having a question mark on
the question so just leaving that off we
also looked at we noticed about a third
of the queries at third of the questions
that people ask on facebook or on
twitter you can yield notices now that
you've heard it right a third of the
questions actually are directed it is
targeted at a specific group of people
most commonly anyone people will say
does anyone know where I should eat in
palo alto tonight or I might say do my
bear Bay Area friends know where I
should eat in palo alto tonight and
that's a significant portion of the
questions people have so we also tried
that and we said we'd said does anyone
think I should watch ET tonight and so
maybe this half would say does anyone
think I should watch ET we also asked
our movie buff friends so do my movie
buff friends think I should watch ET and
then we also had just the standard
should i watch a cheetah night and then
we also play around with a length adding
a couple extra words to make the
question a little bit longer and then we
went and measured the replies we measure
the number of replies the quality of the
replies the speed of the replies that
people got as a function of both the
question phrasing and who
was asking the question and when they
asked a question a lot of the things
that we found weren't that surprising we
found that larger networks provide
better replies so if you have a lot of
friends you're going to get more you're
more likely to get an answer that seems
obvious we found that you get faster
replies in the morning but more replies
in the evening I think that kind of
makes us in the morning we tend to be a
little bit more like up and Adam if you
see a question you're going to answer it
you're going to do it but you're not
screwing around as much whereas in the
evening more people are screwing around
and willing to reply my favorite piece
was looking at the question phrasing and
seeing how to ask the question so we saw
that it's best to include a question
mark and that it's best to target a
question at a group even anyone and that
you want to be brief because adding
additional context so if you want to ask
a question you should say does anyone
know what restaurant I should eat at in
palo alto tonight with a question mark
we also found that early replies shape
future replies you see this sometimes if
somebody says oh guess what I just had a
baby if the first reply says
congratulations everybody else is going
to go and say congratulations afterwards
whereas if the first reply says welcome
to the world little baby then all the
other replies will say welcome to the
world so you see actually common a
common language hear something provides
a link in the first reply other people
are going to go give more links it seems
like there's this really interesting
opportunity for friends and algorithms
to collaborate find the best content I
have a whole nother section that I'm
going to skip and just give a little bit
of a preview on thinking about self
sourcing and this is including the
individual in their own search tasks as
well you know because of the truth is
when you think of when we're talking
about a slow search it's not just about
trying to get a person to the end of the
search experience we've actually found
that people learn a lot during the
course of a search our vocabulary
changes that we're using in our queries
develop so for example if you start out
searching for high blood pressure along
the way you might change that the
queries that you're running to be
something like hypertension the websites
we visit the reefs or
we use a diversity of resources that we
look at they all change as we're
searching and it's really important not
just to think of search as a sort of end
goal that you're getting at but rather
think about it as a as a process to
getting there but i'll save that for a
later day oh this is this is actually
just real quickly because i think this
is fun the little as a little side piece
is one thing that we've found is it is
just to go back one when you think about
you know i talked about how people don't
provide relevance feedback as they're
searching but you do provide implicit
signals as you're searching that provide
in front people with information so if i
ran this query which is a long query and
therefore very likely to screw up and
get me bad results which does you know I
want interested in I our research
related to using additional time in
search and I might get a bunch of crap
back and click on one of those search
results to go explore further the search
engine then has a signal about what I'm
interested in can use that to go try and
identify other information and show it
show it back to me the challenge is
however that changing the search results
to give me that content can be really
disruptive I don't know if people
remember dynamic menus a lot of you guys
are pretty young so you might not
remember this but Microsoft used to go
and try and change the ordering of the
menu items to bring what you were
looking for up to the top so in this
example if perhaps I use this this page
color item a lot Microsoft would go and
put it at the very top of the list so
that I would get to it faster and that
proved to be a total disaster because
you'd be coming here you'd be like where
is page color and you can't find it in
ass up in the top it's not where you're
expecting it even though it's up higher
and easier to find and we find the same
thing with search results if you change
the ordering of a search result it
screws things up for you and you're less
likely to find what you're looking for
as well and so we've done a lot of
things trying to and this is Michael
mentioned a little bit about change
blindness we've done a lot of work
trying to help people
I find things and what we found was that
you really want to bias your
presentation by expectation so if you I
clicked on this search result i'm not
going to expect to see new content up up
above but i might expect to find new
content that's interesting right below
where i clicked so what we've so kind of
in summary we've looked at allowing how
allowing additional time helps us helps
create interesting opportunities and
enables us to start thinking about how
we can incorporate slow resources and
brand in particular people into the
search we focused on crowdsourcing and
trying to use a crowd to wizard of oz
some really interesting new slow search
experiences and we found that the crowds
not useful is kind of component
replacements but can be useful for for
these bigger changes but there are risks
and challenges to working with a crowd
some of which are mitigated by our
friends and that friends provide
valuable and complementary information
to what we're looking for and we can
also kind of manipulate the kinds of
responses that our friends get as well
so I think there's really interesting
opportunity to think about how other
people like our friends or the crowd can
work together with algorithms to create
new interesting content and support the
search process so I'm really excited
about seeing where slow search goes and
if you're interested more here's a bunch
of places where you can go dig up
additional additional content I'm happy
to answer questions thank you just a
couple questions slow questions okay so
in depth is your example of like I'm
looking for a leg Italian restaurant
with gluten free menu of something else
that one um that class of probably isn't
that kind of like um could that be done
like algorithmic a with like semantic
parsing and deadly stuff like like is
that
we like an example of like that actually
requires like slow search as opposed to
just algorithms limitations yeah so I
mean it's a good question and I think
this is sort of this is one of the
really interesting things about trying
to break the process down and get people
involved in various components is what
we're able to automate and do is is
continually increasing in many cases so
search engines do try to parse doing use
natural language processing and other
approaches to try and try and parse out
and understand things it doesn't do very
well on the edge cases a lot of times
and we're continually getting closer and
one of the things that I particularly
like is when you start doing that sort
of thing you collect also really awesome
training data that you can then feed
back into the algorithms and so one area
that we're doing a lot of work in right
now we call hybrid intelligence which is
sort of this hybrid of human
intelligence and machine intelligence
where you collect data by having
basically you start out with people
wizard of oz' ng things and then you
start pulling the people out as you
collect enough data to do it instead so
yeah so look if the framing could shift
in the sense of not being slow in
returning results to me we're becoming
something where it becomes sort of like
a regret engine where it realizes that
like well couldn't help Michael but like
30 you know having the michael high
probability is going to happen to
someone else later so maybe instead of
trying to say I weather wise where
Michaels willing to take a long time to
search what are the opportunities to
essentially use that people running into
the wall to like fix it before the next
person comes along well that's a great
question i think the big challenge there
is figuring out where Michaels screwed
up so that we can help the next person
because fifty percent of the queries at
a search engine seized every day our new
queries that they've never seen before
so it's not easy to really say Oh
Michael had a miserable experience
searching for this particular random
query because nobody is ever going to
search for it again so the important
part is to figure out what's
generalizable
about Michaels negative experience and
how we can improve on that you can see
with distills like this still even that
you know which is this instance where we
were trying to create kind of community
generated answers for search results
that did a we really tried to expand it
and figure out what other kinds of
queries and one of the pieces of that is
figuring out what queries does this
search result work for because maybe
nobody's ever going to ask again why is
the moon orange but somebody might
search for orange moon or you know that
sort of things red moon a lot of these
goals seem like things where if you can
do them faster you could and maybe in
the near future you will be able to do
them just as fast but some of them were
also things where by the nature of them
being slow they were things that you
want that you want to pursue so what are
some other things like that where it's
actually because they're slow that's why
it's better rather than things that
could just be sped up yeah so I think a
lot of the things could could just be
sped up and this is just a way of
getting there because we don't yet have
perfect intelligence I think a lot of it
has to do with accessing resources and
things that change the one of accessing
people are an inherently slow resource I
think also crawley new databases or
collecting new information so it doesn't
necessarily just have to be people but I
might want to you know the contents
changing what's the latest on Twitter
maybe I think maybe I think I'm going to
learn about what happened to Prince if
you can wait a few minutes because that
information isn't even available in so I
have to go out and crawl that
information and process it and think
about it everything else we can pretty
much just you know if it's about
thinking about information you can think
about doing it faster and better really
has to be something that's not yet
available to be inherently slow but I
think it's a good question and I think
there's certainly different different
time constraints on different things
all right everyone slow clap